all right let's jump into this first
story from mediaite cable news ratings
Tuesday April 25th Fox News wins 8 P.M
in total viewers but lands third in demo
I love how they kind of bury the lead
you'd think they'd headline this
similarly to what we did check it out
the hour hosted by Brian kilman on Fox
News brought in 1.7 million viewers
which beat Chris Hayes's 1.45 and
Anderson Cooper landed in third with 678
000. what they're not telling you is
that Tucker Carlson just this past week
was averaging 3.3 million viewers
meaning Fox News lost nearly half of
Their audience when they got rid of
Tucker Carlson and uh okay I think
Tucker is happy I saw a video of him
riding around in a golf course a golf
cart with his wife laughing so he's
probably like great I can start my own
company make a ton of money
here's what gets interesting though if
we jump down to the key demo viewership
take a look at this if we go to the 8 PM
Fox News Tonight 149
000 viewers in the key demo Anderson
Cooper and MSNBC both beat Fox News that
is just laughably embarrassing I mean
look at this Jesse Waters beats both CNN
and MSNBC and then at 8 pm CNN and MSNBC
beat Fox News Chris Hayes
has beaten Fox News
embarrassing Chris Hayes and Anderson
Cooper I mean this is this is honestly a
disaster we should point out a demo you
know the a25 25 to 54 year olds that's
what the ad sales are are based on it's
not total viewers is great obviously you
want a big number of total viewers but
in terms of the the traditional Legacy
Media that these these cable networks
are all that matters is the demo number
and that demo number last week Tucker
Carlson was I mean 400 500 000 I mean
that's as typical
160 000 that is insane and if not 149
149 and it's not just even the 8 PM hour
it's dragging down 9 PM with Sean
Hannity and 10 pm it's it's a massive
massive problem so I got a question for
you though I don't know if you have the
experience in here if I would have
bought an ad on Fox News and I was like
we want to run Monday at 8 pm and then
when you got it and then they removed
Tucker I get my money back right that's
a good question if you bought it
specifically for Tucker yeah do you now
get it that's a good question in fact
now that it's not called Tucker Carlson
tonight that may be your way of getting
it back because now oh now it's Fox News
tonight or whatever they're calling it
in the interim uh yeah no look this is
this is a disaster I mean obviously
Tucker leaving is one thing Tucker is
going to be fine I mean we we've been
kind of I mean everyone in the media is
over text and direct message it's like
the talk of what does Tucker Carlson do
next he will eventually do something
next he's obviously under contract right
now he can't even talk but he will
eventually do something next but what
happens with Fox this is not the same as
what happened I would say when Bill
O'Reilly left or when other top Stars
left Tucker Carlson is a singular voice
and an incredibly important voice in
this particular moment and and they lose
that and that is going to have a massive
preparations I just want to make sure we
don't leave out our good friend Cuomo
who scored 26 000 viewers in the key
demo holy crap and then um Cuomo 11 p.m
get this eight eight thousand in the
demo yeah eight eight thousand holy crap
he probably made a whole 20 bucks off
that show that's that's okay dude if I
made a YouTube video that only got 8 000
views I think it would make like twenty
dollars that's that's not stunning in in
total to be fair in total viewership who
almost got 156 000 and then Cuomo at 11
PM got 80 000.
oh how the mighty have fallen Cuomo I
guess whatever but I think I think
Tucker Carlson's probably gonna you know
he's gonna launch his own network or
something you were saying that there was
like some kind of rumor about why he got
fired because like he was he was hitting
on well not really but no yeah hold on
this is how rumors get started man
just know what he said what did he say
uh that Rupert Murdoch's go actually
this is Gossip I couldn't even tell you
but basically I'll let you tell the
story it has been reported in fact it
was reported even before Monday when
this all you know hit the fan and
Tucker was gone that Rupert he had
dinner with Rupert Murdoch and Rupert is
now now ex-fiance who apparently the
reporting is you know from weeks ago
again this is not related to Tucker
getting fired the reporting is that the
fiance was like obsessed with Tucker
Carlson he called him like this gift
from God and as we the only reason
Tucker Carlson is no longer on the air
at Fox is because Rupert Murdoch soured
on him for one reason or another who
knows exactly what that reason is but
was that part of the tension in the
relationship was the experience of
Tucker himself and whether he's the gift
from God or not I don't know the Chad
Tucker Carlson and the like soy Jack
Rupert Murdoch you should be a million
different memes of this yeah so he
decided to get rid of him I guess I
wonder if it's also because it's not so
much about the relationship I mean the
dude's like 92 years old but maybe that
him hearing her say this he's like this
man is becoming bigger than my own
company yeah you know what I mean he's
like Fox News is me not Tucker no we're
getting rid of him and so but that's
such a bad solution right instead of
continuing to make money off of him I'll
just let him go make money without me it
should have been essentially let your
ego kind of destroy the company I mean
those are big shoes to feel who's going
to step in and be able to fill that time
slot and be able to bring the presence
that gravitas that Tucker brings nobody
you know I think that they're going to
try to Brian kill me run oh yeah
absolutely he's clearly he's knocking
out of the park give him some time I
mean I I feel bad for anyone who gets
put in that time slot we were talking
about this before the show well it's no
fault for taking it yeah dude if if I
was like if I was contracted at Fox News
Hannity or Ingram or anybody and they
were like you're doing 8pm but like hell
no I'm not are you crazy I know yeah
yeah everybody's ragging on Brian Kilby
nobody cared about kill me before this
but now that he took Tucker Tucker's
time slot everybody's making fun of him
yeah it's just like dude you get dead
air you get nothing at 8pm because
nobody wants to take that spot because
if if Tucker was like I'm leaving the
network people would be sad but the fact
that they unceremoniously removed him M
and it may be because Murdoch was
jealous now it's Mega cringe to try and
take his time slot well I sort of Wonder
too if they're gonna try to replace him
with with some kind of bad boy-esque
figures since Tucker was the
anti-establishment guy but someone who's
still brand safe and doesn't push fox in
a direction that they're uncomfortable
no they can't possibly have they could
do that I don't know some some young
upstart that they find guys if you want
to find me you know I can no I'm totally
kidding I would never I would never be
allowed on Fox the whole executive
office at foxes are busting out laughing
I busted out laughing
you cannot hire me I don't apply but I I
really do wonder what they're gonna try
to do because obviously this guy's gonna
have to get taken out of the the spot
he's not going to perform well but I
wonder if there's another element that
people are saying they're getting
they're removing him right before the
election kicks off right Trump's running
DeSantis is probably gonna start running
they just changed that lawn Florida I
think what is it the the rain to run or
whatever it's called yeah where you have
to resign they got rid of that didn't
they yeah
um yeah yeah so yeah it seems like
DeSantis is going to run and Tucker is a
powerful voice propping up candidates
like Trump or DeSantis now he is not
there right right yeah Tucker is look I
mean I've interviewed Tucker Carlson for
about seven or eight times over the
course of the last 15 years I've known
him since 2008. he is you know in in my
book uncovered he talks to me about the
fact that he was Hunter Biden's neighbor
I mean this is a guy who was in The
Establishment in that way uh was was on
the first chapter of the book is about
Hunter Biden's laptop Tucker tells me I
knew it was real from the minute I saw
it because I have emails with me and
Hunter by
he was in the laptop he was in that
world he was in the laptop yes in the
world in the laptop you know a guy who
who knew the Biden family I mean he
tells me in the book that he knew Biden
has dementia because he's heard from
Biden's family that he had to mention
this was before he ran so this is a guy
who was in that world and then became
the turncoat in a lot of the same ways
that Trump did in the New York media
scene and so you're not going to be able
to find that you're not going to be able
to get the guy who knew what was going
on in DC who knows all the same people
and can expose that the left and the
right I mean he goes after the right
harder than anyone else on Fox and if
you're looking for a reason why you want
a guy like that to not be on the air for
the next year which is like the length
of his contract there there's your
reason I mean he he is someone who's a
total differentiator from The
Establishment voice that's on the right
or or anywhere else and he's a threat to
the entire establishment left hand right
he's done it in the segments on kovid on
military policy on the expansion of
government throughout the years I mean
he's a guy that can sort of bring down
entire house just like Donald Trump
right yeah a lot about China too that
the media generally doesn't want to go
near
yeah I mean look in the Dominion tax
that came out which were embarrassing
for sure for for Fox I mean obviously
they settled the Dominion lawsuit the
texts come out he's really rough on
Trump I mean he's calling him like this
evil guy essentially anyways this was
the post-election period and and these
all come out you would think oh that
should be embarrassing and then two
weeks ago he's sitting down with Trump
for an hour-long interview in Mar-A-Lago
and and praising him in some ways and
pushing him in other ways but this is a
guy who can do can do both those things
he can be critical he can be he has The
credibility trump it will go I mean he
was just interviewed about it what do
you think about Tucker losing his job
he's sitting there praising him this is
a guy who's calling him essentially evil
in these text messages that are coming
out in the wake of the 2020 election so
you lose something massive by not having
a voice like that a guy who can it
really cannot be replaced I mean the the
Legacy Media industry is every single
day even if they were doing everything
right less and less people are watching
traditional tv less and less people are
are finding that so when you're not
going going to maximize the time you
have left by getting someone who is a
star a Bonafide star and you take them
off the air you you're you're really
just you're it's the end of it ladies
and gentlemen just a few moments ago
around the start of this show Tucker
Carlson posted a video on Twitter that
says good evening I have no idea what
he's going to say so I hope we don't get
banned here's what he said you think
it's Tucker Carlson one of the first
things you realize when you step outside
the noise for a few days is how many
genuinely nice people there are in this
country kind and decent people people
who really care about what's true and a
bunch of hilarious people also a lot of
those it's got to be the majority of the
population even now so that's heartening
the other thing you notice when you take
a little time off is how unbelievably
stupid most of the debates you see on
television are they're completely
irrelevant they mean nothing in five
years we won't even remember that we had
them trust me as someone who's
participated
and yet at the same time and this is the
amazing thing the undeniably big topics
the ones that will Define our future get
virtually no discussion at all war civil
liberties emerging science demographic
change corporate power natural resources
when was the last time you heard a
legitimate debate about any of those
issues it's been a long time debates
like that are not permitted in American
Media both political parties and their
donors have reached consensus on what
benefits them and they actively collude
to shut down any conversation about it
suddenly the United States looks very
much like a one-party state
that's a depressing realization but it's
not permanent our current orthodoxies
won't last they're brain dead nobody
actually believes them hardly anyone's
life is improved by them this moment is
to inherently ridiculous to continue and
so it won't
the people in charge know this that's
why they're hysterical and aggressive
they're afraid they've given up
persuasion they're resorting to force
but it won't work when honest people say
what's true calmly and without
embarrassment they become powerful at
the same time the Liars who've been
trying to silence them shrink and they
become weaker that's the iron law of the
universe true things prevail
where can you still find Americans
saying true things there aren't many
places left but there are some and
that's enough
as long as you can hear the words there
is hope
see you soon
and uh he was talking about us that was
all about Tim Kessler where can you find
the truth it's right here
[Laughter]
that's his Studio I'm pretty sure I
think it's in Maine or something like
that so uh that was awesome
um to hear from him he's right about all
of that it's really amazing to see that
he's become this like populist
you know there's that Viral meme we
played last night where it shows him in
the political compass for authoritarian
right and he's like the more they have
you talking about race the less the less
time spent spent asking about class why
rich people that shows them like
Shifting the left it starts playing this
communist Anthem yeah so I don't know
what do you guys think man uh it was
fairly vague I know that he can't say a
whole lot because he's he's going
through that contract stuff
I mean I think it's pretty uh it's
pretty on brand for how he's been for
the last God knows how many years I mean
it's just it's classic Tucker
um without the the high-pitched laughter
but I mean I think it's it's it's again
maybe he's just sort of trying to flex a
little bit and show that he's going to
be fine and be able to to operate on his
own yeah without having to to go to a
network I mean who's going to write
everything it's Tucker Carlson started
automatically playing again like who's
gonna write him a check who can afford
to pay him I mean is boring It Off from
500 million dollars to come over to
daily wire like his best move is to sort
of do his thing and I think we'll
probably see more content coming out
just independently from him because he's
able to do it and like you said earlier
he he built Daily Caller yeah and he's
perfectly capable of building another
Network and and being his own man and
not having to be a slave to any anybody
affiliate with your staff does he still
own the Daily Caller or something he's
sold out recently yeah pretty recently
no I mean well first of all this is just
like the quintessential Tucker Carlson
right it's 8 P.M when his show starts
when Brian kill me it is
he's already got almost more viewers
than kill Mead he's got 107 000 views in
this one video he just posted I mean
that's the thing about the internet
versus TV anyway you get more views on a
snippet little video he could put up a
video on Tick Tock and get more views
yeah absolutely Tucker and that's what I
think his next move is he's gonna start
doing Tick Tock dances and stuff all
right so it's about yeah yeah that's
that's what we've we've all wanted to
see is is hope for yeah he's already got
242 400 views oh my God on this video
and I'm assuming it's Twitter so it's
mostly key demo right and Brian kill me
it only got 149. I feel bad for killmate
man I got no beef you know but like what
are you doing but this is also like the
shift right you mean yes traditional
ratings there's not exactly Apples to
Apples with with views on YouTube or
Twitter or whatever but that is a very
very small number I mean not wasn't that
long ago that that three million number
at Fox was 5 million uh yeah we're
talking about five years ago I mean it
was just the the way the audience is
shifting is is happening but but yeah
look Tucker started Daily Caller in
between his time in Mississippi MSNBC
which is you know kind of funny to think
he was a host on MSNBC he gave Rachel
Maddow or start I mean this is a guy who
has had a very fascinating career starts
Daily Caller I remember I interviewed
him in 2010 he had bought Keith
olbermann.com he found out that Keith
oberman.com was was available for sale
and so he buys it he gets the email
address Keith olberman.com and just to
to with Keith he like he he starts
emailing people as if he's Keith
olberman to start scaring people I
interviewed him about it and he's just
talking about how he's the most hated
man in the building and this is Keith
still at MSNBC so he just uses it he's
he's funny he's smart he's different and
uh look I mean apparently now he's he's
free to at least drop some videos every
now and then dude did you hear this
thing about this woman accusing of
sexism yeah she was his old Booker said
that he he like he and others destroyed
her we had the story from the post
millennial I saw this on Twitter
ex-producer suing Tucker Carlson has
never even met him what the how do they
hire these people yeah like does Fox
have like a vetting process where
they're just like right this way sir and
walk through the door and that's it
they're like do you agree with us we
don't know okay well come on in this
person has apparently according to her
interview with MSNBC yesterday has 90
tapes I mean it has spent her entire
career apparently at Fox just recording
people ready to drop this uh yes never
met Tucker Carlson really has no real
beef with Tucker personally as as trying
to make it about Tucker's staff and the
culture that he's started there I think
she you know potentially has him on tape
saying some things that are you know
sexist or whatever she wants to to try
to portray there uh she also buy it no
no no did you see those uh they're
saying they got secret recordings of Ted
Cruz oh yeah I think from her saying
yeah and and Ted Cruz he's he's saying
something yeah probably he's talking to
Maria Bartiromo and he's like he says
something to the effect of if there's
gun to be some kind of challenge to the
election then you've got to have an
actually an actual sanctioned commission
that reviews the evidence and then if
the evidence is there you present it
that's what he says and the left is like
he's trying to overthrow the election
it's like it sounds like Ted Cruz is
trying to stop them from doing it being
like no no no you got to go through the
formal formal process and get a a
commission set up before you can do any
of this and they're they're using Ted
Cruz resisting this stuff as evidence he
was in favor of it yeah honestly you
just to stick with Tucker for a second
the person who was the strongest against
the election fraud stuff on the air at
five times Tucker Carlson right he he
did a 15-minute monologue that was
really powerful that just completely
obliterated Sydney Powell why won't
Sydney Powell come on my show and talk
about this I'll give her the whole night
I'll give her the whole week she won't
come on we've asked for evidence she
won't show it we're telling you this
because it's true I mean that's the kind
of person he was and and all separate
from that just the entire we're still
seeing this now it's three years later
everything that can be part of the what
I would call the Trump Addiction in the
corporate media which I I think all of
this election stuff is they're going to
try to make the story of Ted Cruz's
comment that's like the most Ted Cruz
thing possible I mean it's just like
this lawyer who's talking about oh well
you know like you've got to have a
Commissioners yeah it's insurrectionist
yes he's literally describing a process
like he wants to take over the
government like okay he's demanding hard
evidence and a formal hearing to over to
look at the evidence yeah and their
immediate response is it was his a coup
attempt yep right but this is why people
don't trust the the corporate media I
mean it's it's honestly I I write about
this a lot in uncovered it's like
there's there starts with the seed of
something whether it's you know the
Steele dossier russiagate the media
covers something in a specific way I
call it glance journalism like you get
it at the glance an initial story and
then they just move on to the next thing
and and they never go back and start to
correct it there they're they're so
addicted to to Trump and anything that's
kind of the ancillary the January 6th or
the election process so addicted to it
and the average American left right or
Center is not in that same mindset I
mean they are not just completely
addicted in the way that these media
people are I I've talked to people that
uh could not sleep that had to take
pills because they were just just so
overcome with with this feeling that
they're in this existential fight with
Donald Trump during the Trump presidency
and and it made them completely put the
guardrails of Journalism out when they
tried to to try to take him down and it
was so obvious to the audience and to
this day I mean they have not learned a
single lesson no I think they were
driven insane yeah and I don't think it
was Trump I think it was social media
algorithms because
there's there's no real reason to be so
mad at Trump yeah like any reasonable
person who's like man like if you were
looking at Trump and you genuinely
didn't like him because you like didn't
like his policies or his attitude you
wouldn't be screaming that he was Hitler
you just be like I don't like this guy
yeah they got driven to the extreme end
because the internet was screaming as
loud as possible on their faces exactly
so for example with somebody like Joe
Biden I mean I had to test absolutely
everything the man stands for I don't
have to take sleeping pills because he's
the president it's insane to have such a
small Petty outlook on life my goal is
to go after this person and take them
down for some bizarre reason they saw
him as the embodiment of every principle
that they hated despite the fact that he
was basically a New York Democrat in
many ways at least with respect to his
Economic Policy decision making he was
more socially conservative being there
he was like somewhere between center
right and Centrist this was not some
far-right political leader and even if
he was to be even if he was you know on
the actual right by American Standards
or far right or however they would have
defined it
to not be able to sleep over the guy
your audience thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time